hey action this whoa
podcast is brought to you by blue apron
the apron that is blue sure you guys
know blue apron we talk about it we eat
it
cats eat it dogs eat it everyone in our
family my dog is we're not a everybody
for eight weeks ending on February 22nd
blue apron is teeming with whole
thirty-two bring you delicious recipes
the menu will feature two whole thirty
approved recipes each week like seared
steaks and warm lemon salsa verde and
salsa fin lemon salsa verde oh man sorry
with roasted broccoli and sweet potato I
got excited
add chicken and kale orange salad and
spicy tahini dressing kick start your
new year with blue apron and whole like
they always say happy blue year happy
blue year my friend happy Gareth and I
at least once a week we get together we
cook a nice blue apron dish I think
we'll probably do the roasted broccoli
and sweet potato cuz you're a non meat
guy and you're my sweet potato but man
that warm and lemon salsa Verdes really
just screaming out of me
you're not seeing other dishes are you I
also would like to see you prepare a
little lemon salsa verde yeah it's very
little it's for a doll that's which i
think is gross for me to wear but I'm
wearing don't worry about it I'm loving
it blue apron obviously very convenient
they have a lot of variety a lot of the
stuff can be cooked in under 45 minutes
menus change every week based on what's
in season yeah so Sherrod very flexible
12 new recipes each week you can pick
two three four recipes whatever you want
high quality non GMO ingredients meat
with no added hormones did you have to
yeah okay so like I said it's it's a
super easy thing you can get two person
meal plans you can get family meals you
can get a wine plan where they come to
the wine yeah that will get a whole view
because if
there's one thing I don't need when I'm
drinking wine it's less reasons to leave
my home blue apron is true blue apron
you with more wine okay treating the
doctor play with these dolls all day
again do $30 off your first order while
you visit blue apron calm slush doll up
so check out this week's menu and get
your $30 off with free shipping at blue
apron calm slash dollop blue apron a
better way to cook thank you Dave
nailing that tag just very natural now
see your uh so you're a guy shirt and
and everything seemed pretty set with
you know passing this big sort of budget
thing and I never when I made agreements
never was kind of on board and then you
came out you do okay and then everybody
everybody wanted to kill you okay sure
and everything stopped right so what I'm
saying is this guy needs something
called talk space okay the dollop is
sponsored by talk space which is an
online therapy company lets you message
a licensed therapist from anywhere at
any time all you need is computer with
the internet or you can go to talk space
mobile app that means you can improve
your mental health even if you've had
trouble making it you know in the past
right like you that's fair a lot of
people have a hard time fitting therapy
into their life so this is a great way
to do that you can get stuff off your
chest you can talk about your dad or you
can talk about Garrett's dad a lot of
people talking about my dad you can talk
about your dad Fred you can talk to the
right side friend tell you about your
daddy I'm sorry or either one of your
sons that are going to prison and talk
about how your wife hates you and is
rarely seen with you anymore
and probably doesn't have sex with you
this is also she might be a little mad
about I don't know if you had sex with a
porn star I mean good lord
good lord maybe maybe things are just
very stormy good lord sir
remember therapy isn't just about
venting any most thoughts are dig into
your child memories is also about
practical everyday strategy strategies
for stress management and living a
happier life the talk space
forum has over 2,000 licensed I know my
therapist told me to grow an inch who
are experienced out doing anything in my
70s in addressing life changes we all
face to match with a perfect therapist
for a fraction of the price of a
traditional therapy go to talk space.com
slash stop and use the code dog to get
three dollars off your first month and
chase port for the show that's dollop
and tuck space.com slash dollop talk
about stormy you're listening to the
dollop this is a bi-weekly american
history podcast each week i drinker of
seltzer
liquor of iPad's juke driver Dave
Anthony reads a story from American
history so his friend Gareth Randall who
has no idea what the topic is gonna be
about oh is jam-packed sick arguments
[Music]
Gareth we have a special guest people
miss dim day people for those for those
people who are who are watching turn
that off
we we have a special guest another
person from Garrett's life it is Jose
Jose go ahead and say something was in
the studio looking really happy talk
talk talk I'll tell you what bringing a
cat in the people who missed him Dave
and here he is I'm over it okay
me too that was a good good right up or
get him right up in the camera let the
people see Jose let the people see the
cat oh boy this is going great that was
great
put him back in his tank the cat
obviously lives in a tank it's a heavy
heavy cat seal thing I was watching a
planet Earth with Dave Attenborough and
they showed they showed a young Jose
swimming with dolphins okay I haven't
watched the new blue planet yet I'm
great now I've got it ready I was trying
to get Finn to watch it but he kept
trying to watch you kid wanted to watch
cartoons well okay that's I mean let him
know it's his world so we got dates
coming up a lot of these you know a lot
of our dates are sold out so we've added
second show without a second show in San
Francisco on the second the February
about a second show in Seattle on the
22nd of February on the 23rd about a
second show in Portland Indianapolis we
have added a second show on the 3rd of
March and then Minneapolis sold that on
the 16th of August so we are figuring
out a bigger space so that'll happen
just Metrodome or a second show whatever
but it'll happen yeah we're gonna go to
the Metro dome I don't know what that is
but I think it's cold it's it is just a
big place for Metro we'll go there do
you have any dates or anything I'm
talking about Oh Dave people can go to
gareth Reynolds dot
just check out all this stuff this
Wednesday I will be at the improv doing
a show with Karen kill Gareth and Karen
Anderson and we're gonna show a video of
our our earliest performances that we
have stand-up that we actually
videotaped and then we will critique
each other's I did this show where I
like you had to read your first from
your first stand-up notebook and I
didn't start doing stand-up - a little
later but I did write a lot of stand-up
when I was in college and I was reading
through it and there were so many lines
or I was like I'm just like you guys
[Laughter]
like being like yeah major relatability
Gareth the iconic stand-up Hey I'm like
you yeah yeah I'm just like you gang
except not and then we were gonna be
doing a show in Thailand on in June you
can go to the little dum-dum Club
website and they have the information
there Thailand a place for podcasts
mm-hmm that's right that's their slogan
hundred percent on that so podcasts and
tsunamis that's closer January 10th
1837 oh boy that's a rough era well our
Senna and Pennington sue Larson oh look
you can look at it right there there's
her name okay the last China it's well I
wish it was but that's not well it's not
what it said when I looked it up okay
she was born in Nashville Tennessee she
had 11 brothers and sisters okay cuz her
parents like to do it okay and she ended
up with one good sister Elias and and
Julia and were her parents
our Senna's grandfather had fought under
George Washington at Valley Forge
okay which you're a big fan of I've
always loved it there one of your
favorite battles top nine Julian didn't
last long after Larson was born she died
within a year sure of course have given
birth so mom's out of the picture okay
mom's gone the family that moved to
Texas where they live for a bit
okay but then it was decided they would
move on again this time to California
okay interesting run to get there they
would go through southeastern Arizona
which was not the safest place at the
time or now or now yeah I like when you
add stuff that's like top topical yeah
that's my role here that was really good
I pepper in these topical moments yeah
by the way I've given up the jokes and
characters time people know about that
they figured it out two paragraphs in
mm-hmm
the land had just been I'm sorry my not
stepping it up enough the land had just
been quote purchased from Mexico man
imagine purchasing that from Mexico
you're probably like you know what you'd
be like you'd be like the reverse Donald
Trump you'd be like we want you guys to
build a wall and we'll pay for it and
we're gonna go ahead wrap this up the
Gadsden Purchase it was purchased after
the the United States basically caught
you know one beat Mexico and they were
like hey what do we buy this okay the
Spanish and Mexicans had called the area
a patch area sure after the Native
American tribe that had made it a
nightmare to try to settle there okay
mm-hmm
but Americans will settle anywhere and
rich guy Charles Poston reached an
agreement with a powerful Apache chief
that allowed the miners and Lumberjacks
who work for him to work in the area
safely okay so he strikes a deal I'm I
would imagine he paid them off somehow
cuz he's a rich guy right well that's
how it works
hmm as far as I know and then Poston
pushed Secretary of War Jefferson Davis
to provide troops to protect his guys
that he just made an agreement with the
Apaches for their safety he's doubled
down right okay they all double down
Yeah right okay he's just Corral's basis
right so the Sonora exploring and mining
company made its headquarters at an
abandoned Spanish Presidio in - back in
- black Tupac - buck buck - buck yeah
like like Tupac it's where he's from is
it where Tupac is from yeah interesting
Tupac was born in the desert in Arizona
okay okay so and then as he had asked
for troops to come Fort Buchanan was
built just to the east of Tubac sure it
was isolated it had no walls but it did
bring in new settlers because just
because they figured they'd be protected
with no walls any walls there were no
walls it was just sounds like a house
okay sure
yes I tried to find pictures of it but
there's no pictures because why would
you take pictures of something with no
walls what are you taking a picture
taking a picture of a house take
pictures of houses with no walls yeah so
there's no like load-bearing area's
load-bearing okay I mean why would I
speak up with this attitude you want to
see the Lumberjacks sure you know I do
here's Arizona Lumberjacks at the time
oh wow okay that wasn't a dangerous job
then no now you're totally fine no any
any lumberjack before the 1911 it's I
mean that's still a very dangerous job
yeah be serious like I said I've I'm
here for just mother comment dad's in
lumberjack
so soon Jack Daniels bad show soon
cattle and crops were popping up and by
the end of 1856 about a thousand people
had settled nearby okay right yeah
the Chira waka Apache raiding parties
would ride past without bothering the
miners ranchers Lumberjacks and farmers
on the way to raids and Sonora that's
because he made a deal right right
Poston felt he had found heaven quote we
had no law but love and no occupation
but labor no government no taxes no
public debt no politics it was a
community in a perfect state of nature
well Dave I mean shall we end on a high
note because like this is pretty good
nothing happens after this no no great
nope
30 miles to the east was the Sonoita
settlement it was made of seven ranches
the census of 1860 listed 51 americans
in the valley named as
farmers laborers a cook a clerk a
shoemaker a lawyer a printer and one man
labelled an idiot whoa what why why do
they in the census someone decided or
the man decided that's just what the
census worker called him or maybe the
guy was like I'm the idiot hello I'm
Todd I'm an absolute idiot I'm actually
a [ __ ] idiot yeah we were wondering
should we both be here he's a [ __ ]
idiot and I'm just a total idiot I smile
at apples and I obviously put apples
down my pants again I'm Todd I have a
[ __ ] idiot and this is a [ __ ]
idiot so a lot of crossover so American
women started making their way into the
valley that included the pennington
girls okay because most of the most
people that are met right sound now
American women start coming in right now
the pennington girls they remember they
were gonna make the rid of California
that family right but then they stopped
at for pecan and in June 1857 because a
large Senna came down with a fever okay
so they're in Arizona now because she
has a fever
yeah so they stopped to get a little bit
of help I don't see a picture of her she
is a beaut okay they say in the business
shirt actually very for back then really
hard to tell the attractiveness of
anyone from that time because like
everything's just a little weird yeah
yeah they she I mean she looks like
she's like a doilies eating her I know
they took and she has like Superman
curls I took a long time to take
pictures I believe back then maybe I'm
wrong no that's there was not the deal
you had to hold still for like yeah you
don't still for ages I don't know how
long that went on but you blinked in you
ruined the picture I'm sorry father
I'll try again so while our Cena healed
in the for the Apache stole a bunch of
Eliza's oxen so her dad's oxen get
stolen okay that's not good for the
whole situation right so this force
to halt the journey to California and he
settles down with his 12 kids on the
Santa Cruz River close to Mexico so the
this is when you're moving based on
theft yeah I mean what are you gonna do
a live here yeah that's exactly what
happened okay yeah done the family dug
irrigation ditches and planted crops
they sold the crops to the soldiers and
the miners and the Apaches left the
family alone after they'd stolen all
their well after they stole the alright
we're cool now now we're all good now we
are cool so you know they're stuck there
it's been a couple years hey I want to
see Apaches patchi's our vibe too so he
has eight daughters in an area where
there aren't a lot of ladies to go
around should we be doing this he's
holding you know I'm talking about he's
holding he's oh you mean he's holding
like yeah I'm sure I mean he's got a B
that's got to be like trying to keep
like raw meat away from puppies that's a
good description I don't know if
anything's changed there's a couple of
girls okay so British soldier dr. John
Hall arrived in Santa Cruz Valley in the
summer of 1857 and he went to a party at
the ranch and reported about the women
quote but few ladies American graced the
party but those present were the bells
of the valley good-looking and true
specimens of frontier coquettes see it
does sound like a bachelor spinner like
this is like a bachelorette spin-off
womankind white by that he meant are
scarce in Arizona so all the young
squatters present were deeply smitten
that's just so she's that well-liked one
of the sisters not it's not going great
for her but she's she's hot the lesson
lesson is hot right she's she's the
hottest okay in the area all the
soldiers and miners are after her and
she ended up marrying John page on
Christmas Eve into in Tucson in 1859
okay John was said to be handsome and
one of the wildest men in the valley he
came to Arizona with a famous gunman
named Bill ake and after they were
married John took a large Cena to live
on a ranch on the Santa
River la cena wood tuner the owners ward
which tutored the owners war it's you
know so award is like you bring someone
in and I don't know exactly what it is
but someone's gonna yell at me on
Twitter okay so he there was a widow
she's a Mexican she has a ten year old
girl so he brings her in to like care
for her and and teach her sure yeah sure
so the ranch owners name was William
Kirkland he is he's a rich Richie
Richmond Kirkland Kirk Kirkman or
Kirkland oh no III have to it could have
changed with the thing captain I think
it's John Kirkland so the girl's name is
Mercedes that was early yeah totally I'd
never server Sadie's I know I couldn't
find anything about her and I was like
how is there a girl named Mercedes off
of the car from here by the way I just
saw I just saw an ad on TV you know here
we go you get fired up when you see it
are packing stuff like there's an
emergency right everyone's being told to
evacuate and they're packing stuff into
an SUV video of VW type thing Volkswagen
I'm sure and there and and then they're
like oh we have more room more room more
room and then by the time they finish
packing because so much room in the car
that everyone's already left and then
they're just driving out and they show a
missile [ __ ] flying over the car this
is a commercial like I could not the
hilarity of nuclear war is back didn't
you think that this shift to like
accepting our demise would have a little
more fight to it like I just expected
the Morgan Freeman there's a meteor
headed towards Earth kind of like a what
are we gonna do I'm gonna do heroin and
have sex one more time you know or
whatever like your last-minute thing but
instead we're sort of now like in this
middle ground where we're like I mean it
feels like the checks in the mail am I
wrong game we're gonna go down alright
so Mercedes is she's 10
like other sauna is teaching her how to
speak English on the ranch John works
for the ranch owner but then he also
goes to work cuz the lumberjack 13 miles
east there's a lot of mosquitoes in the
area and soon our Sena
becomes ill again boy she's got a little
malaria well a lot of people at the time
came down with something they didn't
know but now we know it is valley fever
okay it was decided Larson would be
better off breathing air in the
mountains away from the swampy Valley
fever means what you just are like
Valley fever is a really [ __ ] up thing
it can be I think it's like a fungal
thing and it can get into you if you
have like an immune problem you can die
for like it's really gnarly it's in the
it's in the Central Valley of California
it's bad okay but most people get over
it but some people don't base away so
this is a March 15 1860 they take her up
into the mountains Larson and Mercedes
were put into an oxcart supply wagon
headed for the lumber camp that John
works at Mercedes went along because
Larson it was teaching her English and
she wanted to still keep learning the
English lessons must have taken a turn a
little bit I'm dying
I am dying I'm dying I'm dying it's hot
in here hot in here I'm hot are you HOT
I am hot are yes I'm sweating I'm
sweating I'm sweating sweating my eyes
are throbbing
i strapping and I'm sweating in here
yeah my eyes are throbbing I can't see
I'm seeing stars see stars in here I
have diarrhea die I have diarrhea
so Kirkland was worried so she's a
parent yeah she's not smart okay so
Kirkland is worried you know because
it's Apache territory so he sends a
ranch hand along with him Skye Randall
to ride along Kirkland also sent a
rocking chair and featherbed as wedding
gifts okay sure while the agreement with
the cheer waka Apaches kept them from
attacking the wrenches other Apache
bands North had no such agreement so the
group camps about two miles away
from the lumber camp a destination at
night in the morning they ate breakfast
early and then John went ahead to get to
work right so he's got to work he
figures Randall and the ladies would
come up later and then Randall decides
he's he's a deer and he starts tracking
the deer to kill it because he wants to
have that for dinner sure
and Mercedes and Larson waited so now
someone who's dying from mosquitoes and
a 10 year old are waiting right cool
you're not setting up anything so
Mercedes is playing outside and our Sena
is sitting in the rocking chair in a
tent ok
oh she's got one of those little like
miss or just like a regular tent I'm
picturing like a little mosquito I don't
think it's like a veil a body veil so
then she heard Mercedes screaming
interesting moments later an Apache
burst into the tent and let Santa reach
for a pistol but he grabbed her and
yanked her out of the tent
Mercedes tried to run to lure Senna but
another Apache grabbed her altogether
there were five Apaches they were armed
with Lance's and bows and arrows
four were young and one was old he spoke
a bit of Spanish and he told her Senna
that they had killed John as he was
drinking from a stream now so this means
they've been watching them right right
so lar Senna has started screaming for
help and then one of the Apaches pushed
a spear into her breast and she stopped
screaming ahh cuz that'll that'll do it
ok when you say that you're just talking
about the sort of like the the push of
pressure he didn't actually puncture I
know I know he didn't I think he was
like a like what I do in a bar it's like
a threatening what you do in a bar hmm
you just said like what I do in a bar
yeah I carry fear what so what nothing
that's why I don't go to bars anymore
yeah so the Apaches go through all this
stuff in the camp and they're looking
for anything good to take right yeah
sure and they couldn't carry much
because they were on foot so they cut
the bags of flour that they had brought
and they slashed up the featherbed okay
there's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I don't care what
sort of sort of genocidal [ __ ] is going
on leave featherbeds out of it feather
beds are [ __ ] awesome dow is Dow down
did you have a misspelling in your head
yeah I tell you about the time when I
took a summer break and I came back from
summer break guys belt of ovie I was
like in sixth grade I was like that
can't be right
okay so they're just they're just
destroying for no reason other than to
just kind of be like hey yeah well mean
they're not happy about whatever's going
on in the in the territory so so they
take what they can carry and then they
march all our sena and mercedes north
towards their camp
okay randall comes back at noon after
down that deer couldn't find him hey go
away
oh hello now what happened to the flower
in the bed hey where is everyone
I seized obviously there's a problem he
runs to get John any other Lumberjacks
John jumps on a horse and rides as fast
as he can
back to Kirkland's ranch so John's cool
well John's dead but he was fine yeah
well they just said that
so not among everything else they're
fevers and lying so he gets to the ranch
and tells Kirkland what happened and
then a message is sent to Fort Buchanan
and then John and other ranch hands get
fresh horses and went back to find the
Apaches trail okay so the alerts out
there on the trail now they're Sena
marked the trail as the Apaches marched
her off she would break twigs and she
would tear off pieces of her apron and
drop them okay apron great wigs but I
think she's this way there's more twigs
twigs everywhere John you idiot but
freshly broken twigs by these freshly
snapped twigs look they just snapped
these they're this way right over here
look more leaves they were here Wow John
uh-huh a bird in the sky not gonna fool
me bird they're close I can tell by the
cloud
large Silla tries to tell Mercedes what
she's doing and for her to do it too but
at about a pad she heard them talking
and he separates them okay and then he
takes a gun
the worth the gun taken from her at the
tent and he points it at her head okay
and he starts taunting her which I mean
she's [ __ ] what'd you do in that
situation that's just tough if you're
the person with the gun being you know
being taunted at you because it's like
I'll negotiate if there's one pointed at
me but it seems like you just want to
have fun girls just no more Senna
Mercedes sorry Mercedes starts to sob
she's ten sure they do that and then one
of the Apaches picked up Mercedes put
her on his shoulders and marched up the
hill in the end they decided to spare
our lifes Anna's life and they can they
kept walking now loves Mercedes they
their head now lar Senna was she's still
member she's getting over the illness
she's got the illness so she's already
weak and then now they're getting tired
of her slowing them down right okay well
she's spending more time tearing aprons
and throwing twig right she's
preoccupied
what a big apron so yeah I love that she
has an apron on that's always ready for
cooking she's always ready for cooking
are we cookies in the mountains dying
from from Valley fever and don't forget
for when you're better keep the apron
it'll be a quicker transition you
shouldn't be cooking right now but I
think we'd all love around here's what
blue blue a blue apron so uh better get
croutons for that she's got a long dress
on which is great for hiking and then at
sunset the group stops on top of a ridge
at the edge of a cliff and the Apache
who have been keeping an eye on the rear
you know see what's going on I'm sure
him comes up and says the white men are
coming after them they're on the trail
okay so the oldest Apache motioned for
our Sena
to take off her dress
interesting she strips down to her
undergarment which is basically she's
just got a slip on with this he's doing
okay I think they're gonna do some
photos photo shoot oh it's a whole
spread okay got you hurry if we're gonna
get this calendar we got to move now
let's go
I need 12 different [ __ ] looks boys
come on so a second Apache then took her
shoes okay she was then told to walk
forward and when she took a step she was
speared in the back she fell sideways
down the cliff
she heard Mercedes scream and the
Apaches whoop so there's like there's a
differing sure there's different
emotions going on yeah it's like a group
it's like an away game but her fall was
stopped by a small pine tree okay so she
falls about 17 18 feet and then gets
stuck with a spear still no they just
stabbed oh they just stabbed yeah it
went in and out I got it I brought so
you can see what they what their spears
look like okay so they're pretty pretty
fun pretty rad looks like it went
through some spaghetti she got stabbed
by that yeah that one did that was
turned that one's taken from the
spaghetti wars oh so they see that she
fell down and got stuck so two Apaches
climbed down and then they repeatedly
stabbed her in the back with the their
Lance's their spears okay then one
grabbed a big stone and smashed her in
the face okay safe to say let's just say
we're moving on from her she's out right
yeah she's just out so the Apaches left
and they took Mercedes and they took the
dress these Devils I don't know where
you're gone but maybe they just were
they were looking to put on a play like
a Shakespeare we are doing Goldilocks we
will now do Goldilocks one of them put
on Larson no way shoes this maze is far
too hot I cannot eat all this maze and
this maze over here as far as you cold I
also can't eat this
no it's Goldilocks however this maze in
the middle this maze is perfect this is
supposed to be Shakespeare is
golden ox not Shakespeare so one of the
Apaches puts on Larson his shoes okay
just after sunset or Sena I mean they're
playing by a different set of rules I
feel like already they're like operating
like well these while the the lumberjack
people in John are just like she went
this way they're like be her and we will
fool them so so she comes to right after
sunset and she heard John and the other
man up at the up on the top of the ridge
okay but because it was getting dark
they couldn't see her so she tried to
call out but she was way too weak and
then Joss saw her footprints moving up
the hill and they took off in pursuit
okay and as they moved off she slipped
back into unconsciousness
okay so word by now have instead great
word by now had reached the fort 45 men
were sent 17 of whom were trackers
mostly Apache okay they met up with a
civilian Posse that came from Tucson and
as they followed the Apache tracks they
realized the Apaches had split into two
groups Mercedes also have now started
dropping pieces of clothing on the trail
okay so the soldiers Freeman it's just a
Fashion Bug so both the soldiers from
the fort have been fighting with a group
of Apaches who lived in ara ara Viper
Canyon so everyone assumed those were
the Apaches who had taken la santé and
Mercedes right okay the US soldiers were
holding some prisoners at the fort so
they made those Apaches the trackers
they forced them to okay so when they
arrived at the airavata Canyon the
captain gave one of the Apache prisoners
a horse okay and told him to go in and
negotiate for the release of our Santa
and Mercedes interesting okay so he said
they would wait eight days and if he
didn't come back by then then they would
go to Fort Buchanan
of the other Apaches he was holding
there okay that's quite a long
association super long I mean if you
that wondered you're like okay I'll see
you later eight did you did you mean
eight that's nice eight days we're not
idiots we're gonna give you eight days
to close this deal and then we will
start killing you can see it though it's
right I know well we figure the first
day you want to get comfortable in the
second third day jet lag might be a
thing you're dealing with fourth and
fifth days obviously will well I mean we
don't want you to jump in right away
grease the palms a little day six maybe
you bring it up or day seven but by day
eight we expect something out of you and
no running away no even though eight
days is a crazy amount of time for you
to have on your own in Canada in eight
days exactly I was just about to say you
could easily make it to Canada
thanks for the horse make it I mean
surely you could be on a ship of some
kind somewhere else and and that's right
we've given you a horse oh by the way I
hate everyone in the prison they're all
dicks and that's that's how we're
sweetening the pot mmm would you rather
nine to ten days I feel like you're
pushing back all right we'll give you 11
days then we expect you to be right back
here it's 13 days from today friend so a
few days later the prisoner comes back
well that's the captain a prisoner like
what are your options back then you're
like I'll go with what's happening
what's your style I just don't do
anything a few days later the prisoner
came back and said the era Viper Apaches
did not have the females okay but they
knew who did they knew which tribe did
okay and they could negotiate with them
for the girl but the woman had already
been killed okay so this is reliable
information from what we know now for
their trouble and doing the negotiation
they wanted two prisoners released and
they wanted some goods you know ship to
have so now now widow John right heads
back so she did pass and what's what he
just found out so everyone on everyone's
on board with you
change quote there was no hesitating
about us eating to the Indians terms
once sighted as they were and every
effort was immediately put forth to
carry the agreement into effect so
everyone's everyone's like on board get
Mercedes back right so with the two
prisoners the captain headed into the
era Viper Canyon apparently what they
found was quite shocking quote the San
Pedro River Bank was literally swimming
with Indians I never saw so many in my
life okay that's interesting yeah so
what's the play so the prisoner exchange
goes forth Mercedes ran into nine ounces
Kirkman I hope I didn't screw this up
anyway Mercedes runs in a they do the
old you walk at the same time as we you
know they release them at the same time
okay so she the little girl runs into
kirklands arms and told them she was
hungry those are her first words yeah
I'm hungry okay then the group of whites
left as quickly as it possible they got
the [ __ ] out of there and they rode back
to Tucson two days later they got there
and the whole town celebrated church
bells ringing everyone comes out and
Mercedes is given back to her mother
then they hold a military ball and the
captain and Mercedes are the guests of
honor no one knew that Lars Sinha was
still alive oh jeez damn it so she woke
she wakes up in a snowbank she's still
lying bank yeah she's still lodged
against the tree on the cliff she melts
snow in her hand to drink and to wash
her stab wounds smart but most the stab
wounds are on her back which she
couldn't reach right her blonde hair is
now a mass of clotted blood cool yeah
also a good look though yeah this is
this is when she joins a band metal
right Norwegian Iraq she didn't know how
long she had been unconscious just
[ __ ] laying there no idea so the sun
is shining which helps her get warm
she's pretty close to naked as we said
right aside from the slip
and now because she's on the edge of a
cliff she was able to look out and
figure out where she was a place to have
a slip as the edge of the cliff
what kind of keep going so she looks out
and she sees a butte that she knows
which has another name but it's also
called orphan butte she recognizes that
butte yeah it's a tiny [ __ ] hill but
for some reason she I think because it's
out in the middle of nowhere it's just a
little thing so yeah she recognizes that
okay I mean there's such there's so
little to like remember in this time
it's like looks like an anthill
I remember it so that from that landmark
she can get her sense of direction okay
so
lisanna was able to climb up she a too
weak to climb up sorry she's too weak to
climb up right so she decides to slide
down well you're talking about the the
side of wherever she is the side of the
yeah right okay so each inch brought her
tons of pain when she made it down to
the end of the edge of the cliff
whatever it is she passes out and wakes
up the next morning I mean as terrible
as this is these are gotta be great
sleeps I bet you there's nothing like
the before death Kip you know like
literally you don't know what day it is
that's asleep what days and yeah yeah I
slept 31 hours I mean I feel really
rested from but I'm dying but my god
I never showed you were the cool Indian
the this is the canyon or this oh wow
where all the all the huge tribe was oh
wow lookin rad yeah I wanna go there
okay so she's in she's in like a pretty
wooded area now it's called Madera
I think sure Derrick hanging so it's
pretty wooded it's hilly it's you know
it's not like you would think of Arizona
so she's in a Hugh glass Ian yeah she's
in like
yeah there's snow and it's there's
mountains and there's even like looking
at like the idea of like being alone in
an area like we're I mean there's just
nothing no there's nothing like your
plan is like okay yeah I'll crawl for
the end of my life yeah I mean there's
[ __ ] nothing where she is she's just
a little nowhere no reception no she
could cell phone's not working at all so
like you said she passes that wakes up
the next morning son wakes her up again
every morning she wakes up in the Sun
heats her up and then she gets going so
she's now able to pull herself up and
she leans against the tree there's she
looks there's a valley below her she's
like kind of on the foothills I guess of
the mountains there's no water in the
valley below so she sighs she's gonna
stay in the mountains because there's
still snow around it hasn't melted cuz
of the shade from the trees okay so
using orphan Butte to guide her she
started walking
but her shoes have been taken by the
Apaches so she's stepping on rocks
thorns and harsh brush she also has the
valley disease she also got the family
disease so she she walks a short
distance and then she collapses okay but
she keeps on going she lost track of how
many days she was on the move the Sun
would wake her up in the morning and
then burn her during the day lar Senna
was very fair-skinned and she would melt
snow in her hands to drink she would eat
grass and seeds and berries and one time
came across some wild onions that was a
big day
Oh God but you know you things are bad
when you're like oh yes onions her
breath must just [ __ ] night ready bad
but then when you're just like eating
onions like apples you're like
yeah I mean if someone found out they'd
be like after a short time her feet were
just completely [ __ ] sausage like
they just cut onion sausage now that's a
meal pebbles is hopefully this is fair
like producer pebbles because she was
walking had worked their way under the
skin through the open wound so now
there's like there's like little pebbles
stuck in her feet so now she can't walk
so she starts crawling okay and
sometimes she would get enough courage
to walk on all fours like an animal so
she's also scurrying like it Oh
beautiful
well I don't know what it is but it
smells like onions I don't know what
looks like a Barrett it's things like
onions so one day she comes across this
big looking nest of dried grass and she
looks at him she's like that [ __ ]
looks amazing she crawls inside and holy
[ __ ] it's comfortable it's warm she's
about to fall asleep when she realized
she was kicking it in a bear den Oh God
Jesus so she crawled away as fast as she
could I mean this is Goldilocks and then
a little ways away she used her hands to
scratch a hole in the sand so instead of
sleep like a bear she slept like a
badger once you've had that bear like oh
my god it's true I mean she went from
first-class to coach total exei how
would you like just stay in the toilet I
mean you talk about a hibernating den no
it's look at DIRECTV Junior just and
[ __ ] yeah but she she couldn't lie down
okay right cuz we're back
so because yeah the ones on her back so
she would sleep on her knees and elbows
Oh God and then she would keep waking up
dreaming of food sometimes she would
think she could see it and she would
reach out to grab food rockers it's
always fun when you're sleeping like a
wheelbarrow dreaming of peaches that you
can't
so it's like I say she's gone through
the mountains this meant it was harder
than if she was just on you know a flat
surface so let's say no it would crawl
up a steep ridge and then lose her
balance and she'd slide back down down
one day she made negative progress
because she slid further down than where
she started in the morning that's a hope
killer oh dude you I mean these are this
is everything so far is kind of a hope
killer like these people who are able to
do stuff like this I work on another
mental yeah like level you know but yeah
we all know that sensation of work
falling apart but when your life depends
on it
yeah the sliding past where you started
like this is different than writing when
you go I got to scrap the whole thing or
no like when it didn't save for two
minutes and you look back there good
imagine that's your body and it's
stabbed so because she was crawling and
basically had no clothes on the skin on
her arms and leg was now legs were now
destroyed the skin was peeling away
what still she goes on she crawled
during the day on her blood raw limbs
and curled up into a ball to sleep at
night during freezing weather okay
as you do so it's pretty hot yeah sounds
pretty hot story one morning after the
Sun warmed her up she got up and looked
out and realized she was on a ridge she
looked down and saw a road that led to a
lumber camp oh boy and then she heard
voices oh my god voices sooner soon an
ox team being driven by two men is
rolling by so she screams table stakes
I'm a bunch of stakes with a head but
she had so little strength she could
barely muster and they did not hear her
sent up and tore off what was left of
her slip and tied it to a stick and she
waved it over and over and over
but the two men never looked in her
direction and soon they were gone she
put the tattered slip back on and kept
going okay
and then she headed toward the lumber
camp she knows I mean that is gutting
but that's sliding past your starting
point I mean then being there and you're
like take off things waving it but she
also doesn't want to be out on the road
because Apaches right oh my cat this
point okay I think you're at the point
now where you can do the fake I'm dead
oh yeah yeah that's the move right now
just the smell oh yeah oh good someone
killed her with onions so she figured is
about a mile or two away and she's
crawling and so she crawls and she
crawls she doesn't get there night comes
she sleeps again the next day she keeps
crawling and then she happened to find
herself in the middle of her camp where
she had been abducted by the Apaches
okay
and there's flowered coffee all over the
ground where they cut it up and thrown
uh-huh and and all the feathers right
from the feather bed so where santa
starts picking flour out of the feathers
and she made little flour cakes and then
she saw that the men who had just gone
by on the Ox car the day before had
stopped there and made a fire by the
creek and it was still hot oh boy so she
blew life into it and got a fire going
and then using the water from the creek
she made made the flowers indicated
flour into cakes and she ate them and
went to sleep okay I can kill it
better awesome day awesome day I just
them still if I'm her I'm Monday I'm
like thinking back to the fact that
these guys rode past me I mean I don't
have skin but awesome
yeah day yeah killer day the next
morning she wakes up but this time it's
not because the sun is shining on her is
because of the sound of axes hitting
trees and men talking so she crawled
toward the trail that led up to the
take for someone to see fur we're John
I've been working right so that's where
she is she's close to where they are
she's almost completely naked burned
completely red the burns are blistered
right she's been out of the Sun so long
that she's just a blistered red burnt
mess she's a skinny bag of bones because
she hasn't eaten in two weeks or
something and the skin is just hanging
off her horns get it I get it I get it
yes she's she's she's jerky so there's a
black cook named Hampton Brown at the
camp and he has a white wife and brown
is walking down the trail as Larson ax
is coming up okay and so he looks and he
sees this barely clothed white person
with clumpy blonde matted hair
I think the hair colors blood at this
point crawling it's like it's like a
[ __ ] like the ring it's like some
Japanese right right so he thinks that
she's a ghost
okay so she just cannot catch a break
and so he runs you see me so he runs
back toward the camp and grabs his
pistol oh no and then he calls for all
the other of the Lumberjacks there and
he tells him what he saw we're gonna go
kill a ghost they think they think that
she's actually a squad that has been
kicked out for some reason okay so not
everyone's going with hampton's good
they still all get guns cuz like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so so when they get there the ghost
rasped out like she says her name and
they're like what the [ __ ] so Brown
picks her up and carries her back to the
camp at which I would imagine she's
going oh yeah no skin no skin no skin
hold me like I don't have skin all right
I'm gonna float her down the river to
where we are so he takes her back his
wife starts to washes her basically
takes the pebbles out of the soles of
her feet oh that's a
Scot pebbles in the cells of a feat she
pulls the thorns that are all in her
skin and then they're open meat parts
and whatever she has she cleans all the
festering wounds that she had and she
feeds her and then after she dressed our
Senna in clean clothes I assume super
carefully I assume no solids at this
point well where's she going she's no
Butthead yeah but there's men around yes
they just saw her but you know cleaned
up you know I'm telling you if this is
me
you keep me nude and you just keep me in
a bed and you keep cleaning my wounds
and looking for Patton you're not
surrounded by horny Lumberjacks oh the
hell I'm not
[Laughter]
so where's Senna ask for tobacco and
went to sleep she's a huge she loved
chewing tobacco I like I like what I'm
hearing I was her jam cello January
Jones action I like that was she saying
something what school she had been
believed dead for 16 days one of the
Lumberjacks wrote as fast as he could to
kirklands ranch so John was in Tucson at
this point and Kirkland gave the
lumberjack a fresh horse and he kept on
riding to Tucson now even though John
had been told by the Apaches that Larson
was dead he never actually really
believed so he was actually was his
theory he was actually at this time
prepared well he just didn't trust them
yeah that they told the truth so alright
ok at this point he's preparing a third
expedition to go look for her and then
there's lumberjack rolls in and tells
him John jumps on a horse and heads for
the lumber camp and he brings a doctor
with him and a friend when they arrived
they couldn't believe what they saw the
friend later said quote what a sight
emaciated beyond description her hands
and knees and legs and arms a mass of
raw flesh almost exposing the bones
caused by crawling over the cruel rocks
uphill and downhill the doctor looked
loose
lisara over and told John there was no
hope for saving her she would die but
John wasn't about to give up how the
hell is that the diagnosis now well what
do you mean well like she got through
all of that with all this and now she's
like found why is he like it's not
looking good for it's like doing these
are basically looking like a Skeletor
situation over two weeks yeah but he's
now saying let's not bet against the
Rocky Balboa of mountain I know but
you're if you're a doctor this time
you're like yeah well I'm give her
chewing tobacco so you gave her tobacco
you gave her some snuff hmm all right
anyone tried to get more blood out of
her coffee yeah I don't know what we
should do but she's gonna die scarer
have you tried scared definitely scared
nope then let's fill it with some of
those feathers we'll make a day of it so
Jon's not gonna give up he puts listen
in a wagon drives as carefully as he can
yeah down to Tucson yeah um the doctor
saves him back up there in the wagon and
then keeps a watch over her back in
Tucson a traveling Englishman came to
Tucson at this point and he described
her as quote sunken temples the loops
drawn so tightly over the job that each
tooth could be easily counted through
them oh wow I mean it's hard to like I
tell you right the arms scarcely larger
than a man's thumb Oh God and a
continuous cry for food well give her
the food yeah seriously
I looked at my thumbs
so she barely clings to life for several
weeks and then somehow slowly starts to
recover okay
but see the thing is is when you're when
you go that long your organs start to
shut down yeah there's problems so for
sure when the friend who had come
accompanied him to the camp saw her
later that summer he was quote amazed at
the blooming woman before me ah hello
well she is back in sex shape is she not
John
sir I purely as a friend but she is very
sexy
well I think no no I'm not gonna no I
won't even do it on this basis nope I'm
going to masturbate well that obviously
will allow her scars finishing the plant
Harve
Wow all her scars slowly healed when he
was better John took our Senate to a
cabin he built near the mouth of the
Madera Canyon he okay where she was
there they could start their married
life over okay I Mulligan it's about ten
miles away from the ranch in Apache
country what are they doing that for I
don't [ __ ] know why would you go back
there why would you go to an isolated
cabin in the middle of nowhere when you
have just a fancy country do you
remember the Apache experience yeah
because it was a great look back on the
good times like the snow melting and the
times I didn't slide past my beginning
point of the day you know what I
remember best what's that River
flowering River flower kegs by the way
that's him making that call that's not
oka Mon it's like lightning it can't
happen to someone twice On January 27th
1861 the air viper Apache Raiders
attacked a ranch in the Sonoita Valley
they kidnapped the ranchers 11-year old
steps on the previous fort captain right
the guy we saw earlier he he was gone
now he'd gone back east cuz the Civil
War is about to kick off and a new
inexperienced lieutenant was brought in
to pursue the Apaches there's a new guy
they're experienced so he confronts
Chiricahua chief Cochise oh what a name
yeah Cochise denied any involvement so
the lieutenant had several of cochise's
people taken hostage and then I guess he
didn't get what he wanted because the
lieutenant had the
just hung I feel like this is gonna take
a turn well now these are Apaches so it
turns out they're not into that and
they're badasses so a war was on okay
all started by a [ __ ] idiot
the Apaches struck all over ruthlessly
warriors attacked the Santa Cruz Valley
killing 150 of the people on the ranches
there okay so at this point bad policy
bad yeah bad call
around this time John page took a second
job escorting a wagon to Fort
Breckinridge he needs extra money
because our Sena is pregnant On February
20th 1861 his party was watering their
horses along he wash when the Apaches
attacked three of the men managed to
escape the rest did not John was killed
when they found him they found that his
horses throat was cut but not by the
Apaches turns out the men held off the
natives for over a day and they killed
the horse to drink its blood oh sweet
bastard why wait three days what three
days before you drink the board damn you
really drink a horse anjing why I argued
about different [ __ ] right now okay
give me a moment sir you knew this I
can't imagine the idea like when you
said basically the ideas that I like in
my head the Apaches just slit the
throats just to be dicks or some version
of that
yeah but I'd drink its blood you were
just near a river right yeah well but
that's for strength and also like how do
you it's not a Capri Sun like it's got
to be like all right everyone get your
mouths under its neck oh we can only do
this waterfall one yeah I mean they
really squirts out here we go the way
would I do it so John is buried right
where he's found then his handkerchief
his pocket book and a lock of his hair
were brought to La Sante by by whoever
was saying he was dead
good news bad news large center
um he's dead but look at we got his
kerchief
here's his hair and hankie he's a
pocketbook and we took a part of him the
part from the top of the head we were
gonna take a nose or an eye so we didn't
want to be graphic so we reckoned maybe
we just give you a part of his hair if
some of us hair here you go anyway
congratulations you can put it on that
baby you got a ring you are single all
right brings me to my next question
oh boy our next question we're looking
to beat husbands with a wife so Lord
Santa's father came for her and brought
her to the family's home so her sisters
would take care of her the family home
is it's it's actually I believe it's
like a destination now maybe that's not
a gazebo oh come on you're telling me
you're not having Tiki barbecues in
there so in September she remember she
was pregnant so she gives birth to a kid
Maryann okay her sisters take care of
her the Civil War comes about and so a
lot of the soldiers and I moved out of
Arizona okay so the Penningtons are
worried that the lack of military would
lead the Apaches to becoming more bold
sure so the stone house along the Santa
Cruz was now in very dangerous territory
at one point
Apaches came and lar Senna had to flee
with Maryann and hide in a fortified
mine well at this why does she not go go
somewhere else anywhere else here the
[ __ ] guy no far from here who is just
like kicking it in oh there's a war on
and there's Apaches and oh by the way I
can't defend myself against the Apaches
yeah what the [ __ ] am i doing yeah so
okay so she remains the family now
starts constantly moving from place to
place so there who's signing it
doing the business 1864 there and to
back and were the only people living
there now remember this is where they're
like thousand people the fort is nearby
now they're the only people okay
everyone else had left after an Apache
attack in 1861 les sent his brothers now
are always carrying rifles in case of an
Apache attack around this time both lar
Sena and her daughter came down with
smallpox good lord
so she survives her daughter survives
okay
and they even survived the Cure which
was a strict diet of bread and water
that's how you got rid of smallpox
that's what a [ __ ] idiot right
I'd be like cake whatever you got let's
do this
gone down well we believe this is caused
by your sweet tooth you've been getting
a little thick yeah so but is that that
worked or no work
Pennington family did not fare well as a
group for years they kept moving from
town to town to work to find work and
avoid Apache attacks the men got jobs
driving wagons and were gone for long
periods so the young boys in the family
started carrying rifles that were longer
than them interesting in 1867 one of our
Senna's sisters died of malaria okay
another brother Jack was killed by
Apaches when they stole his ox and
eyebrows and then he chased them oh boy
come on I mean you gotta know when to
fold them bud but his eyes are super
close together so Wow what a move you
there give that back oh I'm dead oh that
was a bad idea my life is done now
whoops in 1869 listen also look at that
collar it looks like someone like broke
his body yeah he doesn't know how to
turn his head yeah which way am I facing
in 1869 her father and another brother
were killed by Apaches while working on
the farm okay
the rest of the family have been decided
to move to California right so they're
doing it it's all happening smart right
on time too there's some Apache warriors
good lord I mean that's just [ __ ]
badass badass the rest of the family
goes to California but they only made it
20 miles because then one of our
senators sisters came down with
pneumonia 20 miles in they can't get it
they can't they can't catch a fire but
how long is that I mean this is this
family should be called can't catch a
break
what is that three days maybe 20 miles
in two days maybe it was very fast so
she died for bread and water if she died
what they were looking for a doctor so
now the only members of the Pennington
family left are lar Senna and one of her
brothers who then he got the [ __ ] out he
moved to Texas Butler Senna totally
stubborn refuses to leave Tucson
okay and she falls in love with a man
okay who I don't have here upper left
second husband or in a second husband
his name is William Scott a Scottish
lawyer Scottish he's killing it yeah
just tie it in a knot never you daddy um
they had two kids okay she then went on
to live a very quiet and happy life
until her death in 1913 okay so after
all that [ __ ] she just stuck there and
married a Scott yeah
Mercedes did not live long she got
married at 18 to a County Sheriff and
died at 26 during childbirth okay their
fourth child all right
so Wow anyway that's that's the female
Hugh glass yeah right yes yeah she's
[ __ ] badass yes Hugh glass ceiling
cute what huh
felt like it might work in my head boy
that's crazy though
there really is there's like a I truly
think I mean how do you think you fare
in one of these positions like you're in
a position where you're gonna have to
survive 16 days of just pretty much
crawling and drinking snow no I make it
no I roll up off the cliff
absolutely great I'm off the cliff if
you're seeing me in the if you're seeing
me in the large center of the Hugh glass
moment what you're seeing is you're like
why is he chipping that big rock out and
then I get that big rock and you see me
just start smashing my own head in as
hard as possible
I like like I get trying to survive the
first cold days but once you can't walk
and then your your legs and arms are raw
wheelbarrow grab a good fruit that
you're dreaming about no you're not
[ __ ] Hey look at me I'm eat yeah oh my
god yeah there's just I don't know I'm
my guess is that that is if you could
hook humans up to it you would find that
that's in like 1% of people I can barely
handle it when I don't have internet
yeah and I've seen you in such a
situation you do not handle it well I
don't you start crawling on all fours
eating seeds yeah yeah wouldn't you
[ __ ] straighten out your goddamn
pendant if you're gonna take that
[ __ ] photo yeah but you know I mean
yeah truly I mean I do notice how long
they're actually waiting in these
positions but I mean that's a like you
know that's a that's pretty good for
before pictures were really happening a
lot yeah so I mean if you told them how
our phones were gonna ruin pictures
right yeah so I'm gonna people are
saying they don't like listening when
we're talking about photos but I'm gonna
start trying to I'm gonna put him up
somewhere I guess maybe a grammar point
yeah that was the point but now they're
yelling big yell people yell what did
they say I hate it when you guys are
talking about what they look like yes
okay
I mean how long do we talk about what
they look like for like five minutes
total a show
hey when you when you put up the YouTube
video can you can you put markers where
the pictures are is that too much of a
pain in the ass too much pretty dances
that's not gonna happen but we
definitely reached out to Aaron and he
said no terrible attitude
nice try Aaron all right anything I got
uh I got nothing all right
carry carry on is always saying carry on
I never said that
carry on our my wayward son is that our
thing i Theron cut the feed now
carry on
[Music]